three minutes let's play something new
six bishop g7
let's just play fast
i don't know whether this works i guess
it does
muscle 38
c6 queen a5
just playing some random moves
b1 bishop v6 i have to watch out for
some knight defense
maybe right now
leads to an end game where i'm not worse
i guess
f5 i should be more careful i'm allowing
all sorts of stuff
c5
yeah i just love c5 which is very stupid
from
numbers
yeah it's very bad
okay
let's go f5 and hope the bonding is not
lost
yeah i should definitely not have
playbook f8
now here on d5
yeah i think now i'm back
um
i was in real trouble and now i think
i'm okay
so king d3 how do i get out exactly he
wants rookie too i'm pretty sure about
that
let's go rook g6
rookie 2k6
wow okay f4 what am i doing
this is a bit weird though
hmm
let's see
look at fate king of it look at six rook
g2
he'll go king c3 i guess g7
hmm just give him rook d6 for some
reason
yeah just not playing well so
okay
b4 wait
bloke h2 d7 king f6 would be 7k 27
oh not good still not good
um what do i do
a5 this looks stupid but
i'm gonna try like group d7 rook f7
and rook f7 king f7 b85 i'm just gonna
go king g6 and should be winning for me
because this double bonds don't count
and i have a
powerful protected passport
a3 should fix with a4
probably
give a check first i'll see what he
wants
a4
rook d7 rook f7
probably still nothing for me he has b5
he's so active he just can't lose this
position
unless i managed to we don't time
somehow which is very unlikely as well
okay let's see
i might lose this good time
need to speed up of course e3
c7 king d7 that's why i'm removing this
out
i should be able to draw
before c3
maybe i'll even win this i think i'm
winning actually
a two
it's gonna be if i'm able to flag him
right now
okay
okay good game yeah that is a very bad
game from me but
okay i managed to win
that's enough